e aí galera que assistiu ao planalto com
vocês
olha espero que esteja tudo bem comigo
está tudo ótimo nosso canal chegou a 3
milhões de inscritos e tem música nova
para você refaça o tempo fazer a música
nova sábado agora voltar em fortaleza o
primeiro show só de música sabe a dor
dia 4 5 horas da tarde no centro de
eventos do sebrae vai ter ingresso
ingresso lá no via sul na loja ramos
olha a primeira descrição que não sei
que já sabe como é que é passar de
cumprir então vamos à música cinco
minutos você olha pro céu
neste sábado o teu beijo só pôde desejo
eu beijo tem sabor de mel sei que não dá
pra esquecer nem pra não votar num papel
então esquece menina tem olhar me
fascina e ficou minutos com vocês pensam
cinco horas no céu a tudo você é tão bom
seu toque o cheiro a tua pele de um
sorriso deu jeito no chão me faz querer
ficar perto de você eu abraço me
comporta
parece até o pai do meu jeito de menina
sem sorriso que fascina e me faz
arrepiar
eu achei diferente essa química gente
que me faz que ele não te deixa a
madrugada são demais sua voz atuais até
pelo celular
eu fico feliz todo dia só tem fim e
alegria que você não me liga e cinco
minutos com você
são cinco horas no céu
este sábado o teu beijo pode desde o meu
beijo tem sabor de mel
sei que não dá pra esquecer nem pra
votar num papel então esquece menina
teoria me fascina e cinco minutos com
você
5 um minuto você
são cinco horas
el esse sabor do teu beijo sabor de
desejo do teu beijo tem sabor de mel sei
que não dá pra entender nem pra botar um
papel então esquece menina olhar me
fascine cinco minutos com vocês são
cinco horas no céu
é é a cada música nova se tiver gostado
você gastar fazer só deixar aquele burro
eu gostei sim aqui no youtube está no
twitter da pgr teve e tatá no estado
essa marca em seus amigos lhe poder ver
o facebook dá aquela pontinha e não
esquece é de fortaleza sábado agora a
gente tem o encontro cinco da tarde a
fátima bernardes não há em fortaleza no
centro de eventos sebrae ingressos na
loja romeu lá no verso támbém bate o
ingresso ao todo mundo comparecendo e
sábado vídeo novo blog normal como
sempre e vai sair o rap e de 3 milhões
de inscritos em participação de uma
pessoa
alô galera